number 18
awesomely fun effect from the Panipat
[Music]
[Music]
in modern times the art of being a thief
has always been portrayed as a suave and
cool profession and as the most
internationally wanted and renowned
thief there not many cooler occupations
awesome leap on the thirties a
descendant from a generation of thieves
starting from his grandfather arson leap
on that's third generation descended for
those of you who are figuring out the
obvious origins [ __ ] a snappy
dressing suave gentlemen he sports a lot
of charm when it comes to stealing the
crown jewels or ruining the ladies but
fire army favors using the Walther p38
and for cars he seems to like driving
the mercedes-benz SSK while also having
a fondness of fancy gadgets he is also a
connoisseur of international food and
wine now
occupation aside does he remind you of
anyone else bond James Bond yes his swap
demeanor can be reminiscent of bond the
times don't let's leave the similarities
of that shall we with him being French
in one big English so I don't have to
tell you how well that ends and also
those sideburns along with his crew of
jig in the quake drawing accurate
sharpshooter going on a swordsman with a
sword that can apparently slice through
the space-time continuum if needed and
Fujiko the femme fatale character
proving that fanservice did exist in the
80s and at that time it did need boobs
it seemingly run on the deadly ride
beach volleyball engine he's a thief
capable pulling off any heist and
getting away with it being an incredibly
slippery character who's almost
impossible to catch and this comes from
his many skills of being a thief
physically wise he's amazingly flexible
and fast allowing him to sneak into the
tightest spaces and has also used it to
perfect the art of getting the [ __ ] out
of there one trouble car
he is also able to skillfully drive cars
motorbikes and planes while only
occasionally breaking the laws of
physics and seemingly able to crack any
safe or free himself from shackles in an
instant while his quick wits allow him
to outsmart any target while UC gets
more than Lutz though personally I think
his most impressive skill is his ability
to impersonate basically anyone he
fancies I'm not sure how he does it but
he could perfectly mimic any person of
any height race or gender right down to
their voices which is kind of scary to
think if I were a wealthy man making out
with this chick I just pulled only to
find out that I was seduced by swag
dressing smooth-talking monkey with two
rats growing on the side of his face
those sideburns though then again I'm
from Tyler Moore half the woman there
secretly men anyway so I should be used
to it by now
haha self-deprecating racism always hot
in this tell is the ICP inspectors any
gutter who he is always able to evade no
matter how close he gets this is
supposedly because his cunningness
allows him to always gives any cut to
the slip but personally I think it's due
to the fact that loop on looks like he's
suffering for anorexia giving him pencil
arms well as any gutter seems adamant on
carrying hand cast made for people with
the risk of size of lampposts I got
plans as a submitter no me chart Oh
penny who says Amin and Iowa Bernie
attack you
what am i there though while loop on can
be undeniably cool the times he seems to
flip arbitrarily between suave cunning
thief into crazy wacky idiot who
couldn't charm his way out of a paper
bag even if this goofiness is only a
knack to fool his enemies or just to
trick people into thinking he's not as
intelligent or sneakier than he actually
is
it happens all too often for him to top
this list also even though this guy's
supposed to be in the International
ladies man
his actual successful woman very much
depends on the mood of the current
writer who has the ability to make him
into his through talking charming
womanizer or dissing to a bumbling
French Ponce though the latter
definitely applies when we focus on his
infatuation with fujiko's as the master
of the femme fatale role Fujiko has
always been able to rely on her feminine
charm to get her way with men and this
is especially true when it comes to the
loop on she has no hesitation in using
double-crossing or betraying loop on to
the point where finding either Fujiko
has betrayed the team is abuzz
surprising as a sunrise day in the
morning and every time he just comes
back crawling like he's little puppy
fetching a stick and does he get
anything for it he'll know every time
loop on gets a whiff was obsessed with
her
he would always fail because either she
would be playing with them or she had an
ulterior motive or we find out her
vagina is made out of a spring-loaded
Blockson glove but the point is
something would always come up he means
his [ __ ] but then again how he could
burn any girls with sideburns oh that
it's a [ __ ] mystery to me because of
his tendencies of goofball antics and
outbursts of wackiness he does get a
lower spot in this list but when it
comes to smooth criminals in the anime
world no one is smooth or cooler than
loop on the third
number 17
Light Yagami from death
[Music]
one
[Applause]
exactly as planned a wise man once said
absolute power corrupts absolutely
and it is certainly true when absolute
power comes in the form of a black
notebook owned by some drag queen reject
of a deaf God who has nothing better to
do than [ __ ] in the human world and
corruption comes in a form of an
intelligent young Japanese high schooler
who is also really bored and has way too
much free time to kill
Light Yagami is one such guy after by
chance discovering a black moment that's
been dropped in the floor he soon finds
out that this is no ordinary notebook
but is actually a notebook that can kill
a Death Note though being the swamy get
their ears he has to give the audience a
don't be long monologue explaining how
stupid and childish a notebook is and
describing how sick and twisted the
whole idea sounds before he finally sits
down shuts up and tries a [ __ ]
thing out the suspect has been found
dead inside yeah that's right not so
stupid now is it you smug yep from there
on he declares himself a god of this new
world and starts killing off criminals
one by one before he is sooo noticed by
the police I'm not teenage super
detective named L and his dubs Kira by
the Japanese people on the Internet
originating from the English word killer
further cementing notion of the internet
is full of sick and twisted individuals
and that the Japanese have no ideas how
to pronounce her bloody elves properly
per her get it hell huh shut up being
one of the smartest characters out there
light is able to put his intelligence to
good use when ridding the world of
criminals and invading the police using
the many rules of the Death Note and I
mean enough [ __ ] rules to write
a book about he's able to inventively
plan out his executions and also protect
myself with having his battle of wits
against L making for very interesting
debate on the values of justice
we'll hunt you down wherever you're
hiding and I will eliminate you I am I
am an alum geek oh hi I'm Troy McClure
contrast L whoo let's face it looks like
a weird obsessive nerd who can't even
sit down into the share property and
hasn't seen the day of sunlight through
his life like the good-looking
well-dressed well-mannered guy who has
random woman falling for him even though
they're arguing is [ __ ] and is seemingly
able to make most remedial were tossed
up like the most epic thing since
Charlie Sheen started taking a drug with
Charlie Sheen yes I went there and no
I'm not gonna put that potato chip seen
him because that's joke is so old now
that I might as well to piss our little
saying believe it or the we for being
called the we even if it does look like
you have no blanking contest while
playing it whether you agree or disagree
with his methods of justice it's
impossible not to get caught up in his
face I mean it's no secret it becomes
somewhat of a prick later on but even so
I still found myself just in awe of how
well four tires bands work and not in
the way of aizen's ridiculous I planned
out your entire [ __ ] life resides
awesome stuff but stuff that was
actually believable even if he was just
using and killing people left right and
center a testament on how well he can
manipulate can be seen with his
influence even hood for your life people
some people argue that light had good
intentions at the beginning and I was
trying to do things for the greater good
most people have to ask if you really
justify a guy he fancies himself a god
right from the get-go even if he is
babbling on about saving humanity for
the greater good yes he may have
convinced himself and even some of the
audience of his good intentions but
rifle mechanic is treated this more like
a game than anything else
focus more than beating anyone who
opposes him but getting rid of crime in
society eventually not only killing
innocent policemen but downright
taunting them just for the moment they
died so can we really say that a person
like this was in the right place at the
beginning to be doing this for the
greater good
his quick transition to a god complex
made even go higher and higher no
Peregrine's prick a meter even if we
water down cool prick of that but all
this never to be accommodated into a
huge fall from power in the end when he
got caught from the combined effort of
some guy who looks like he's posing for
game a fashion magazine and midgets el
rip-off 2.0 sparking a deleted reaction
for light that resembled a reaction for
a whiny loud 12-yard kid who have been
teabag to one too many times and Xbox
Live
Church you keep killing [ __ ] this
childish reaction bumps an analyst
number 17 but whether you think is a
misled ally of justice or an arrogant
teenager with a god complex his
influence intelligence and ambition
ensure that his pen is most definitely
mightier than a sword 16
major Motoko Kusanagi from ghost in the
shell'
you people are cops there's no hope for
justice in our system now straighten up
your own ass before whining about the
world or if that's too much wear a
blindfold zip your mouth and live in a
cave or the alternative before Pokemon
ruled the world in Dragon Ball Z tick of
the Cartoon Network Akira and ghost
Nichelle were responsible for feeling
the initial boom of pocketing socially
awkward otaku x' or watching his new
mysterious thing caught anime in the
comfort of their mother's basement ever
since then Motoko the major Kusanagi has
always cemented herself as one of the
most badass female anime characters in
history whether it be in the original
ghost in the shell' movies or in the
more recent TV adaptations levelling
occult get sack making us a like a
euphemism for some kind of scrotum but I
digress a cyborg employed as a squad
leader attached cores operation even at
section 9 she always maintains a
commanding presence and is never afraid
to stand on her authority as team leader
and commander president she does as she
doesn't take any [ __ ] from anyone
getting both fear and respect from
fellow team members and commanders alike
this is due to incredible efficiency
when it comes to getting the mission
completed because I determination and
dedication makes us seemingly
unstoppable when she is on one always
being able to keep calm and quickly
analyze any problematic situation that
arises to come up with a solution to
solve it as quickly and efficiently as
possible
while commanding her team to successful
mission after successful mission well I
say she stays calm in any situation but
she does sometimes get angry and in
those odd instances when she does lose
her temper due to unforeseen
circumstances like I don't know a
five-ton [ __ ] robot trying to stomp
on her head you might want to stay the
hell away from her
hey Saito fork over that weapon
her increased strength and agility which
she gets from her sleek and sexy Bionic
body makes her tough as nails when it
comes to combat being able to go
toe-to-toe with any guy when it comes to
a fight or using firearms and hey when's
the last time you ripped off your own
[ __ ] arms trying to dismantle a
walking tank barehanded in addition to
our determination and tactical abilities
she also has great skill when it comes
to hacking being able to quickly hack
most computers machines or even other
side walls to take control of them allow
her to win some fights without even
lifting a finger and to top it all off
she's also in a large minority on the
face because she's also a woman instead
obligatory sexist kitchen joke here it's
no surprise at the anime world is very
lucky when it comes to strong female
leads especially in the era of male goes
doing my way things in ammo a way with
more stuff where the [ __ ] that even
means or if more than a probably better
off the bras cleavage and or underwear
whenever possible or in a more likely
case but the trough their bras cleavage
and/or underwear in a [ __ ] mow a way
whatever the [ __ ] that even means the
major breaks this trend showing us a not
all women are there just to be cute to
show some tits will get kidnapped all
the time war instead obligatory sexist
kitchen joke here and breaking a
stereotype served by other real-life
shows giving us the impression that all
girls want a dildos talk bad dick and
shoes and lesbian sex though I have to
say while she is a butt-kicking female
her main outfit seems to be what I can
only describe this battle lingerie which
only you see was there for some life
fanservice but it's fine because the one
hand her bodies are her real body Boca
police cybernetic body would are human
parts losing her brain's organs and a
while their assets but on the other hand
damn she can kick some ass in that with
her big-ass guns and a big-ass ass
seriously what the hell is that
unfortunately she doesn't score higher
than as this good mother aren't really
many uncool points to go against her
there aren't really many standout core
points either she doesn't really do
anything with much enthusiasm if you ask
me sometimes being too well robotic and
she doesn't have too many badass
features on her belt either okay single
handedly firing a high-powered sniper
rifle repeatedly point-blank in
someone's face is pretty cool but in
terms of badass feats there are a lot
better on his list and the terms of
attitude there are a few cooler still
with a determination of the terminator
the skills of a professional soldier and
that this is one unstoppable chick you
really don't want to piss off
you
you